we are looking live at massive crowds of
Border crossers being processed by Texas
authorities a bit of perspective on the
scale of the crisis that has border
agents saying they are simply
overwhelmed check out the numbers from
yesterday a staggering 4500 people
crossed in the Texas Del R sector alone
in Eagle Pass one border patrol agent
called it quote the worst day we've ever
seen in total the southern border saw
more than 12,000 cross yesterday
now Texas is taking action Governor Greg
Abbott just signed a law Texas Senate
Bill 4 that empowers local and state law
enforcement to arrest people they
suspect of crossing the Rio Grand
between ports of Entry meantime the
crisis at the border is a growing
concern for everyday Americans in a new
Fox News poll 34% called it an emergency
45% say it is a major problem just 33%
of registered voters approved appr of
President Biden's handling of the crisis
63% disapprove raising rightly held
concerns among Democrats about the
impact on Biden's re-election
campaign Joey we've been saying for
quite some time every state is a border
state do you think the Biden campaign
will see that yeah I grew up in a Border
Town uh Dalton Georgia 78% Hispanic but
mostly Mexican immigrants from the 9s
and late 2000s I just spoke with a good
friend of mine I spent 12 the last 18
days in Texas good mind Eric Kaiser's
police chief down in jingon Texas he
said listen people think these are
migrants coming to work in fields and
factories they're not they're are people
from all over the world coming with
criminal records of their own and
nefarious intent of their own and even
if it's just 10% of the people coming
that's that's way too many for our
country to call ourselves safer to have
a a border but really this move by Abit
is really smart because it it it's a
win-win either way it's either a win for
Abbot if for some reason the B
Administration doesn't challenge this
then Texans say Hey you took care of me
he sets himself up for Senate or maybe
presidential run because Texans and
Americans go wow thanks for taking care
of us or it's a win if the Biden
campaign challenges it because then the
Republicans can sell for the next year
that the Biden Administration I mean uh
basically puts more effort and good
faith into protecting those that would
disobey our laws than those that have to
live by them and are susceptible to
those that disobey our laws and let's
focus for a moment those who bear the
brunt of this absolute Siege so last
hour you spoke with a national border
Patrol vice president art Del quto so
let's watch that for a moment we'll get
your thoughts on the other side he's
pretty much nailing it he's doing what
others aren't doing with the
inactiveness of this Administration and
that's part of the problem but you know
what it's not just uh you know in Texas
it's happening throughout the entire
Southwest border and you know you asked
me for worst case scenario I don't know
anymore Harris because every single day
it's worse than the day before it's just
chaotic throughout the whole border I
get asked is our border broken and I ask
back what border are you talking about
because I do not see a border anymore
the national border Council represents
thousands of people and art Del quto has
been leading them and he says now they
are
outnumbered in Eagle Pass for every 200
illegals coming across the border you
have one border agent now you want to
talk about morale issues you can put
that in a bucket but I'm going to talk
about safety issues and I mean yes for
the country because we don't always know
who's coming through with the people
that we even trying to identify but then
there are all the Goda ways going around
all the checkpoints and we know so far
there have been more than a million of
them but I'm worried about our agents I
I I want them to have what they need and
the support that they need we need
military at the border now and the
president may not
be strong enough he may not have the
intestinal fortitude that it would take
to put just some some stop Gap at the in
this process you don't need Congress to
give us a little bit of time and to stem
this tide Trump didn't need Congress to
do that would have loved to have it have
it they looked at bills he wanted to get
something done Republicans weren't on
board with that Democrats weren't on
board with that but we have to go
forward now this is a bad situation for
the country and by the way Del quto is
right and you are right too we just need
a win for all the politics I don't care
who's winning and that the country needs
a win
and Tammy let's talk about impact of
Senate Bill 4 so some quipped but
rightly so well you need to be build
bigger prisons the reality too is with
the thin drinks as Harris pointed out
they're not equipped to even process or
put in jail all of these people so at
the end of the day is this about Optics
and if so will this work what will work
well it could be an attempt to get again
to the Supreme Court in 2012 scotus
overturned key parts of an Arizona law
that was very similar same Dynamics
which they say said you can't arrest
people the state can't do this because
federal law takes precedence so you
can't do that so it's interesting to see
what Abbott's intentions are that it's
not about the constitution in that
context it's federal law which Congress
can change so these are the kinds of
things that we are looking to have
happen and also part of the bill is
about building the wall Etc but I think
they know it's going to be challenged
especially because of that scotus
decision in 12 about Arizona and Mar I
wanted to get your thoughts on this so
the Biden campaign co-chair Texas
congresswoman Veronica Escobar she was
talking to Politico about the border and
she said we have failed over and over
again I do worry that Democrats will get
blamed simply because the president is
in the white house I hope not but I'm
afraid of that happens to be
there in the White House right and then
the natural response as Tammy just said
is frankly well the policies are
yours yeah I mean look the Biden team I
think fully realizes is this is both a
security issue a border issue and a
political issue I think Tammy to your
point about what governor Abbott's goal
is I think you hit the nail on the head
Joey when you said he wants to be a
senator or maybe run for president but
look Congress does have a role to play
they don't have to do everything Harris
as you said but we have a Democrat a
republican an independent right now in
Washington Working an extra week at the
holidays to try and get a deal on
immigration because guess what we can't
get Ukraine or Israel funding because
Republicans are holding that hostage if
we don't get an immigration something on
immigration have a problem with that
like you want to oppose somebody else
border before you want to ours I I think
that immigration is such an intractable
conflict and at political football in
our country the current president it's
it's more intractable you know why
because it's more dangerous let finish
here I want Israel to get the funding
now I want Ukraine to get the funding
now I don't want Republic to get I I
don't want Republicans of Congress who
in this Congress have had the most
ineffective lazy you know Congress that
has done nothing has gotten nothing done
except for historically take their
speaker out of power
pass no bills start an impeachment with
no evidence and they can't even get
Israel funding because they're fighting
some political fight over the Border
that's never going to be signed into law
come on let's be serious here I think
the Senate can do something and you
simplify it so much but let's not forget
about the months and months where we
didn't get an allocation of all the
money that was going to Ukraine and no
one is saying that the effort isn't
worthy if this president had given
Ukraine what it need at the beginning of
the war we wouldn't be
sitting about this issue we could have
it is true a bunch of Republicans are
saying Ukraine is not worth fighting for
anymore well I'm just terrce faul I'm
not a bunch of anybody and the facts
wear out that we needed to do more early
but now we need an enumeration of well
where is all the cash going and let's
look at all of it what is wrong with
that but in the meantime why not our
border first yeah which 67% of Americans
agree they went funding for the border
now hey everyone I'm Emily compano catch
me and my co-hosts Harris vulner and
Kaye mckin on outnumbered every weekday
at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or set your DVR
also don't forget to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights